واحد من مشاهير السوشيال ميديا والعروض
الغنائيه المسرحيه نا لا شهره كبيره من
خلال اعمال الفنيه ذات القالب المنوع
والمختلف فيعليان الكوميديان متعدد
المواهب يغني يمثل اضافتان تقديم برامج
ترفيهيه ومقاطع ساخره فضلا عن ستاند ابنتي
اكثر من خمسه ملايين متابع موزعون على
صفحات ضياء على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هو في الاصل المهندس معماري ورياضي ولاعب
كره قدم كان يعمل في الولايات المتحده حيث
ولد فيها لكن هو ترك المجالين وقرر ان
ينتقل بين الاردن ومصر والبلاد العربيه
ليوكليس وقته للكوميديا والانتاج الفنيه
او عبده
[موسيقى]
دي قاعده في وكان واينات يعني اذا بقدر
ليش
لاي تراي بحب احاول يعمل لعبت كراتين مبدع
دراسه لانه الشهاده للعيله هاي لما ابوك
بعدين يعني ضحيت بكره القدم عشان ال- اا
الدراسيه فلما صارت دراستي وال- سوشيال
ميديا حكينا نجرب مره هون مره هون
طب ضياء يعني هلا مثلا الاغاني اللي عم
تصدرها انت اليوم لو ما انت كنت مشهور على
السوشيال ميديا وكوميديا وبتعمل كوميدي
ممكن كان الناس عندها فضول تسمع اغانيه
كيف
انا لما بلشت على السوشيال ميديا بلشت اذا
استاندر كوميديا فلما الناس تحبش الترقل
او التنوع المشاهد خلاص
من البدايه لكن نجح كان نجح كثير كمان
اكثر الناس شويه مش بتقابله لانه الناس
مثلا
[موسيقى]
ما الناس اصلا بتحب العفويه بكل شيء بس
بوم بوم اجت عفويه
والله على المسرح
[ضحك]
انت كنت كوميدي وناس تحبك وعندك متابعين
بالملايين على مواقع التواصل شو اكتشفته
اول احد العروض اللي عملتها ستاند كوميدي
راح اخسرها بعد التصوير ههه
احلى شيء فيها انه لما طلعت مره عملت
ستاندر كوميدي عملت ربع ساعه 10 دقائق
ونزلت عن المسرح والكلام حفله كبير زيت
همم
15,000 شخص انا ما بدي انزل يعني خلصت
اكثر من صوتك
والتقدم برامج ترفيهيه بين المقاطع مقاطع
السخريه وبين الغناء شو تفضل انت شخصيتك
تحديدا
ضحك المزح المضحك اه باحب بس انا شغله
الميوزك امين تبس للعرض للمسرح انا بدي
اطلع المسرح بدي اقعد ساعه باحب اسمع
المسرح كثير حلو بس تطلع وتشوفي عالم
مبسوطه بدكش تنزل
الشاشه حلوه بس العرض لايف مباشر انت مش
شايف اللي بيحبوك
كل يوم لتسمعنا اغنيتك الجديده
اصعب قشر الدنيا بتضحكنا بس صح وبعدين انت
بتروح على مختل- اماكن مختلفه
كثير شامل
ليش لا بس الناس الفكره بالناس ما بتتقبل
هذا الشيء يعني انا كثير تغلبت فكره ان
الناس انه ضياع اللي بيعمل عرض ضيع احنا
بنحبك بنضحك مرات بنروح العرض اللي بيكون
متى فقرت الكوميدي بروما بدي انا مش رايق
مش محضر مش مجهز الحلو بعروض اللي ميوزك
هو دي جي وبتمشي عليه اغاني وراء بعض كل
عام وانت بخير
[موسيقى]